what is the core of what it means to be
a writer and a
Storyteller to be a Storyteller is to be
human every single person is a
Storyteller whether they recognize it or
not some of us tell stories to the world
about who we are through the clothes
that we put on every day some of us tell
stories about who we are to the world
through the words that we speak and some
of us tell stories about who we are
through the stories that we write
down every person is a Storyteller but
not every person is a
writer those of us who have been called
in many ways
assigned
this terrible and wonderful task of
being
writers are the those of us that cannot
help but to
write there's something about truly
being a writer that is such a core part
of your identity that you just don't
know any other way to do it you don't
know how to move through the world
unless you're able to put the thoughts
you're having down
somewhere and maybe it's writing them on
a tablet or a journal maybe it's typing
them on a computer and if none of that
is around I'm convinced we writers would
go and grab a stick off a tree and in
the dirt scribble our thoughts down
because we just can't live in a world
where these thoughts remain imprisoned
inside of
us there's something about having to get
them
out a story Storyteller who is conscious
of the fact that they are a Storyteller
who
Embraces the fact that they are a
Storyteller then gets to choose what
medium that they want to tell and share
their stories in perhaps they're just
going to share those stories among
friends and family or a close loved one
they're going to just use the words that
come out of their mouth perhaps they
have a certain skill with paints or with
a pencil perhaps they have a certain
musical skill that they can express it
that way perhaps they're an actor and
they can embody the story in their very
self but for some of
us we don't have those things what we
have are
words and we spend our
life playing with those
words discovering new words and finding
ways to arrange those words in a way
that impacts another
person in some
ways it is a holy sacred calling to be
someone who
is given the
gift of arranging words on a page in a
way
that someone feels something when they
see
them it's almost like working in the
world of secret codes in Mysteries and
symbols to be able to take these lines
these circles these
scribbles to arrange them on a page in a
way that when someone sees
them they feel
seen they feel like they're remembering
something about who they are in the
world what a calling what a gift to be a
writer and you said that sometimes
technology is a hindrance to that that
it's better to use a pen or a pencil
yeah I'm someone who really believes in
physically writing things down not just
doing everything on a
computer there is scientific evidence
that we remember more and process
information differently that we actually
write down is opposed to the Mindless
way that many of us have become so good
at typing um but also there's something
about connecting to the ancient aspect
of the art form of
writing this is the way that people have
been transferring thoughts and IDE ideas
inside themselves to the external world
for hundreds of thousands if not
millions of years is by taking an
instrument in your
hand and by making marks on something
and having those marks mean
something not just to
you but to others that others would come
after you and see those same marks and
experience it's for just the tiniest
moment what it was like to be in your
head inside of
you that feels
otherworldly that feels
sacred that feels like what it
means to be a conscious part of
something larger than
ourselves The Mystery of the
universe how does story allow writers
and audiences to explore
theme one of the greatest discoveries
that a writer can make are the specific
themes that they are most compelled
by many of us think early in our writing
careers that you know there are
thousands of themes that we want to
explore but I think the hard truth is if
you look at any great writer any great
filmmaker you find just a couple of
themes that they keep coming back to
over and over and over again Spielberg
comes to mind to for me automatically
because Spielberg keeps exploring the
mystery of childhood over and
over many other filmmakers and writers
explore the theme of just trying to get
back home whether it's ET trying to get
back home or ODS I trying to get back
home this idea of just trying to get
back home very very common theme that we
see I
find that I am drawn to two themes in my
work secrets and Second
Chances so much of the work I do so many
of the stories I tell revolve around
secrets and second chance
es I have an exercise that I try and do
every year to see where I'm at
thematically with the stories I'm trying
to
tell and I go every year and I make a
list of the 20 films television shows
graphic novels uh novels anything that
was a a fictional story that I
encountered and I make a list of the 20
favorites that I had of that last year
and then I go and I try and identify two
or three themes out of each one of those
and then I start to circle the themes
that I see
repeating and I
know those are my themes and I'll tell
you it's always the same themes that
keep coming back to me and they usually
can be categorized by secrets and Second
Chances these are the two ideas I have
been given in life to keep telling
stories about now many of the stories I
tell are in different genres and
different mediums and you might on the
surface never know that those are
stories about Secrets or second chances
but I do those are the themes that I
keep uh engaging and I think you know we
we can look at um Patty Jenkins comes to
mind is another you know filmmaker that
uh I think keeps engaging many of the
same themes I I saw even uh an episode
of Television that she directed that
reminded me of some of the themes she
was exploring in Wonder Woman isn't it
amazing that we keep returning to these
ideas because I don't think we ever
fully come to conclusion around the
themes that are of interest to us we
just keep revisiting them in new and
different ways trying to pull them apart
in a different way that we might have
new or additional insights into what
that theme really is
about this is what keeps writing
exciting for me it also drives what I
find myself pursuing when it comes to
what I watch and what I read I Know
Myself and I know the types of stories
that resonate with me one of the
greatest gifts a writer can give
themselves is getting to know themselves
well enough to know what are the big
themes that I want to talk
about and usually not always but usually
there's just three or four
tops sometimes there's just one or two
but we find ways to keep circling back
and
re-exploring discovering what those
themes have to offer
us I love it and what would you
recommend for someone that wants to see
um maybe five different films um on
secrets secr and second second chances
yeah so secrets and Second Chances make
their way into all sorts of different
stories and films some of my favorites
started we we'll have to start from when
I was a child the first time I saw
Raiders of the Lost Ark I knew I was
seeing something about a secret there is
this hidden treasure buried
somewhere it's the same reason that
years later as an adult I Saw The Da
Vinci Code and had the exact same
experience and then I went back and read
the book and had the experience all over
again because there was a secret there
there was the uncovering of a
secret Second Chance
is I end up weeping in these
movies um one of my favorite Second
Chance movies was a Disney film called
the rookie and it starred Dennis Quaid
and it's about a major league baseball
player who is injured but gets a second
chance to come back when he's much older
and play professional
baseball it is a powerful powerful story
and when I saw it in the theater I began
weeping about halfway through the story
and I wept through the whole rest of the
film literally people around me put a
hand on my shoulder and said are you
going to be okay I was like I'll be fine
this is just really really impactful um
that that story of seeing someone get a
second chance was so compelling to
me I think the reason why stories of
Secrets and second Chan is um have have
been so important in my own work and I
seek them out is my family has had a
very very complicated relationship with
secrets and Second Chances and I have
seen the power that Secrets have held in
my family and that when they were
revealed the the impact and explosions
that they
caused and I've longed to see those who
were devastated by that impact have a
second
chance and that's why these
stories are so important to
me